SEP 28 be disclosed
just go do all some would call us a
broke worth it oh yeah we're gonna be
trying out the dollar menu today in a
bunch of different restaurants of
dolphins redstone first recently I'm
more excited for Wendy's I don't know if
that's important information
I love Wendy's one is my favorite we're
on our way to Taco Bell I'm gonna get
the cheesy bean and rice burrito and the
spicy tostada yes welcome to the after
party oh I smell it all we're doing it
in the order that we pull these out Oh
classic cinnamon twist styrofoam they're
gonna be good I'm in tight I wouldn't
hate a block and a little bit of sour
cream what I don't think so
we're open the next thing I'm gonna take
a break from this air and then I'll pass
it over okay I'm not gonna let that
[ __ ] it hmm how do I feel about without
Fritos I love Fritos which is like the
inside of a cabin smells what does a
very there's like a smokiness more
nachos oh here it is follow a spork the
did Taco Bell invent the spork that's
where I first encountered them in
chiku's I just like new ways to eat the
same thing the bear doesn't end it is
cheesy rice and beanie I want to eat
this while I'm falling asleep I was
feeling I'm not gonna love this one
it's just gonna be cheap dry peas right
oh my god there's still more
- Davis - that's chicken one piece my
mouth has farted do you hear that
[Laughter]
cinnamon rolls
I don't want it okay I thought they're
gonna be like a cinnamon bun oh they're
in sided the mousse inside no pretty
good a lot of redundancies then all of
it
total they're dollar menu just a value
of their dollar we're going to try a
dollar man you today gonna eat it right
down in the old fashioned way through
your mouth I'm trying to get everything
on the dollar menu that's a dollar look
what you want to drink
I would like believe it or not a diet
coke this is gonna be exciting just pop
right in they're all so hot it really is
made fresh here you go buddy a little
too wet for me whether Jesus Kasich
cheeseburger why are they so I like the
tiny little onions it's like different
layers but the same layer at the same
time hey we do regular meat chicken and
spicy I should just like put two or
three chicken McNuggets in there
the cheeseburger was so like happy and
you should have waited
oh you know seven out of ten seven out
of ten for me
Mickey D's I was gonna give them a six
out of ten yeah yeah because those
chicken sandwiches all right we're at
Wendy's now I'm gonna get three four
four fours right yeah okay so the four
four four you get fries you get nervous
you get a drink
very perfect cities over the first
surprise mm-hmm
now when are you used to have different
fries you know they're all the friends
they would get wet in the bag yeah which
I like going on to the Nuggets yeah
definitely better chicken meat under the
birds not you machi junior bacon
cheeseburger boom boom I love that
they're square it looks like a classic
drive-thru burger what am I gonna be a
vegetarian not today
ten out of ten I think for the whole
four of our four things the four before
is so nice even if you don't want all
the things give it to a friend it is
totally not brought to you by weddings
but when do you want chocolate call
mister Buster's up well let's go bring
this food back to mark okay you're
welcome mark you have a lot a lot to
catch up on
yeah yeah we're gonna give the rest of
mark taken up bro it depends how much
did it cost
yeah
[Music]